I posed you a question on Thursday and I
just sort of you know as I do I let it
simmer I wonder if you came to a
conclusion we had a look at this idea of
modified growth the decay or growth and
decay we've constraints and we developed
a couple of equations that made it work
okay we developed for example a
different differential equation
different differential equation not this
guy not the one we're familiar with like
this DP on duty okay the rate of change
of the population or the temperature or
massive red stuff is not directly
proportional to whatever it is okay how
is it different remember how the
difference equation look different
depending T equals what you have you had
hey at the front but then in brackets
well depending on the question what did
we have it was it was some number maybe
you could call it m for under buck okay
and then you took away what your current
value wants ok so the classic example
for this would be just um what
temperature okay and I very briefly
mentioned Newton's law of cooling you
can quote it for me hey yes
careful careful how's it quoted in like
you learn this in physics right what's
the actual for me the actual letters
they give you have they called it
something different up here it is
actually casualty right is a capital T
here yeah yeah minus T naught or e is
the other one that I see I think now
hold on okay so what you've got here is
a difference between the temperature of
your object and the ambient temperature
right so that's what really changes the
the actual temperature now what was the
actual equation for P or 40 not the
differential equation but it wasn't just
a e to the KT or AG to the negative KT
what was different let's let's take a
decay situation let's let's go with
temperature and you've got sort of an
ambient temperature room and we talked
about boiling water dinner which starts
100 it comes down to whatever it feels
like 24 or something like that okay you
have your normal decay situation but of
course the difference would be there's a
question hanging around isn't it okay so
we looked at this and we thought okay
this is really good this makes sense of
this models these kinds of information
because of situations that we looking at
right and then I pose this question back
to you I said look back at that question
about HSC question that talk about
termites right and it talked about the
same kind of thing it talked about there
being some kind of constraint the
termites I think they max out it 450,000
10 months or something like that but
this equation looks very different to
this equation like I mean there's an
exponential and there's a negative there
and there that's about where the
differences sorry that's where the
similarities and now did anyone come up
with a conclusion why did they give you
this free to equation here I don't
remember
we talked about the limitations of using
this model if I use this as a sort of a
arm if I thought about the termites we
had something like this you had some
constraint on the population of time so
that they could reach up to here but
they could never really get there right
there for you something like this or
flip it upside down in order to make it
match our graph right what was the
problem for x 0 what does the population
look like do you remember sorry i meant
for time less than 0 it goes negative
doesn't it it just sort of borders right
through the axis and doesn't care
because that's what Exponential's do
like that right now that's why there was
kind of a limitation to this we liked it
it was simple is very similar to what we
looked at before it leads us to this now
does anyone know what this looks like
anyone hmm what tools do we have in our
toolkit to work out what it looks like
what might you guess what let you try
what can we do I could do some limits
couldn't know now you're going to guess
well let's think about this right let's
take the limit as n approaches sorry not
in time approaches infinity of em what's
happening to it what's it going towards
a on to now I think that's why in the
situation before it was like I think you
worked it out to be 900,000 or something
like that so that's why you were heading
to excuse me 450,000 okay that's nice so
I could um I could draw that that's
that's this situation year let's put a
on to up there oops and
so on tending toward that on the
positive side what happens the other way
what's the limit as we think about time
in the other so I should have a native
there other direction toward negative
infinity what's it looking like what
yeah you're going to get a constant over
to constant plus and this guy well he
becomes enormous doesn't hear right
because you've got double negatives
happening it's a huge number you're
going to go toward zero hmm so I need
another asymptote down here don't I okay
you've got to mass and takes that's all
I know about this thing can you tell me
anything else I can work out intercept
couldn't on time zero that just gives
you a over 2 plus 1 over 3 I call that
area to ship to know so i guess i
overthrew be there about something like
that so i'm passing through them is that
enough information you could probably
make a pretty good guess at this point
but just to be sure let's think about
you you know tons of information that
will help you with graphing something
like this right why do we differentiate
let's see what happens dl on duty it's
question rule but that's okay it's not
too bad what do you get stop me off to
plus e to the NDP there's my V times u
dash which is 0 okay that's nice minus
minus what
a times V dash right yeah so I should do
the derivative of the inside right and
is that sorry no I'm sure there's my
resume to those there's my b dash
already worked it out okay that all
right yeah over V squared not much point
expanding that is there okay can we tie
this up a little bit hmm double negative
I e to the negative T yep over all of
this mess okay what can you tell me
about this function now that you know
its derivative this kind of money
station points and the original graph
does it have any stationary points the
answer is no why not why does it have no
stationary points okay know much about
it no stationary points because what
defines a stationary point the
derivative has to be 0 right the only
way that the derivative is 0 is about
it's always at the numerator denominator
don't matter doesn't matter what you put
in the dryer you'll never get 0 but your
numerator pain isn't it no stationary
points as either the native tea it's
never equal to 0 for all values of x
that are real anyway okay you can stick
an imaginary stuff like I am pie and get
natives but that's not what we're
dealing with x real okay no stationary
points can you tell me anything else
about what this thing's going to look
like now do you know this
it's always increasing how do you judge
that does that okay well number one e to
the negative T right that's always
positive isn't it it's always going to
be above the axis and it never crosses
that's good and this guy weighs a square
so I didn't even like to think about him
okay so therefore this thing's always
increasing does that make sense we're
expecting to be going down here and up
here over there right are there any
other features you can tell me what
might you guess that this looks like
looks like if you stop in here in and
you just start thinking about its
derivative I think this guy as a
stationary point I think about him as a
function I think he has a station in 1
i'm pretty sure he's an even function as
well it looks even to me okay what's it
going to look like well if he has a
stationary point what does that mean for
the original function it's got point
inflection right do we have enough
pieces I think we've got enough you go
up here you go to approach that way
right down here you've got to approach
that way what are you expecting to be in
between a point of inflection because
this is concave down this is concave up
otherwise they're not behaving
asymptotically so there you go now all
of that work for such a shift simple
shape but what does it mean what does it
mean why is this for such a
weird-looking function so much a better
model than this can you see why now ah
it's ingenious isn't it when you look at
a part of it like say that part okay it
looks just like a regular exponential
and that's how population's start don't
they're they're small enough that the
constraints like food in space and all I
can't be aren't a big deal so they're
just the population skyrockets great but
then eventually they'll get to some
point where it's like sorry no
wouldn't eat termites so you just have
to sort of slow down your radio growth
and that's why it's happening up here
okay so that's why I have an almost
identical situation what were you
looking at it was like a disease there
was a disease more than I gave you right
and I think it was something like 1,000
wasn't it chickens 1000 on 1 plus c e to
the something Mike I remember something
like that okay yeah yeah that's right
yeah different number up here so you're
going to get this model again in and
again when they want to combine this
idea in here now you can see why this is
extension 1 growth indicate it's
actually quite a different beast from
this very simplistic way of thinking
about it okay